zuverlässlich der Unterzeichnung des
Kooperationsvertrages zwischen dem
österreichischen Bundesheer und dem
Zivilschutzverband begrüßen ich begrüße
die Verteidigungsministerin Frau Claudia
Tanner und dem Präsidenten des
österreichischen zivilschutzverbandes
Herrn Andreas hanger Frau
Verteidigungsministerin ich würde es um
ihre Worte suchen ja vielen Dank sehr
geehrter Herr Präsident Szenario des 21
jahrhunderts das sieht man immer und
viele von ihnen waren ja auch schon
dabei bei unserer sicherheitspolitischen
Jahresvorschau wenn die Expertinnen und
Experten meines Hauses das Risiko Bild
erstellen für Österreich und da wird
dokumentiert dass es über diese Form der
Krieg und Konflikte hinaus
Terroranschläge Pandemien selber
Attacken Naturkatastrophen oder eben
mögliche Blackouts gibt die auch zu den
Herausforderungen zählen denen wir jetzt
und in Zukunft begegnen müssen und diese
zu bewältigen haben werden das heißt das
sind ein bisschen die gehen weit über
das militärische hinaus und darische
hinaus und daher brauchen wir auch die
Zusammenarbeit mit zivilen Partnern das
ist so ein ganz besonderes Anliegen mit
zivilen Partnern und Organisationen und
der österreichische Zivilschutzverband
ist wohl der perfekte Partner auch dafür
weil er seit 60 Jahren über 60 Jahren
wertvoller insbesondere
Präventionsarbeit in Österreich versieht
die Themenpalette die reicht ja von
Maßnahmen zum Schutz vor Hochwasser
Naturkatastrophen über Strahlenschutz
bis hin zu einem möglichen Blackout das
Hauptziel dieses Verbandes ist es die
österreichische Bevölkerung auf diese
Gefahren auch hinzuweisen und sie Krisen
fest zu machen ein sehr bekanntes
Beispiel ist auch das jährliche testen
das Sirenen aber auch die
Sensibilisierung der Menschen immer dann
wenn es um Vorbeugung und das richtige
Verhalten auch in Notsituationen geht
und das heißt der österreichische
Zivilschutzverband spielt damit auch
eine ganz ganz wichtige Rolle in der
umfassenden Landesverteidigung wir
hingegen also österreichisches
Bundesheer wir stehen da Bevölkerung bei
Bedarf im Rahmen von Assistenz einsetzen
bei der Bewältigung und der Abwehr von
Gefahren zum Schutz und zur Hilfe
Leistung zur Seite ja das haben ja nicht
zuletzt die zahlreichen Einsätze bei
Naturkatastrophen aber auch die
vielfältigen Einsätze und
assistentseinsätze und
Unterstützungsleistungen in Zusammenhang
mit der corona-krise eindrucksvoll
gezeigt ja sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
der Schlüssel zu Bewältigung von Krisen
und Katastrophen der liegt im
Miteinander der liegt in der
Zusammenarbeit denn nur gemeinsam können
wir es schaffen mein lebenswertes
Österreich zu bewahren weil es geht am
Ende des Tages und den Schutz und um die
Sicherheit von uns allen ja von daher
werden wir heute und ich freue mich sehr
darüber und bedanke mich bei allen die
auch im Hintergrund mitgewirkt haben wir
werden heute diese Zusammenarbeit mit
einer Absichtserklärung besiegeln und
ich möchte Ihnen kurz sagen worum es in
diesem in dieser Vereinbarung geht es
soll zum ersten der jetzt bereits
laufende Austausch zwischen meinem
Ressort und dem österreichischen
Zivilschutzverband institutionalisiert
aber auch intensiviert werden es soll
dann zweitens insbesondere der fachliche
Informationsaustausch in den Bereichen
Krisenszenarien gefahrenanalysen
Krisenkommunikation und staatsarbeit
forciert werden zum dritten sollen wir
es Bundesheer im Sinne der umfassenden
Landesverteidigung auch die Möglichkeit
bekommen dass unsere
informationsoffiziere Vorträge über das
österreichische Bundesheer über aktuelle
Bedrohungslagen im Rahmen von
gemeinsamen Veranstaltungen zur
Verfügung stellen und die Damen und
Herren des zivilschutzerverbandes
wiederum die werden bei diesen
Veranstaltungen dann ihre fachliche
Expertise einbringen ja und viertens
werden wir als Verteidigungsressort
unsere Expertise insbesondere bei der
psychologischen Betreuung von
Opfern von Katastrophen oder
Krisensituationen bei Projekten des
zivilschutzverbandes zur Verfügung
stellen ja und fünftens werden wir
gemeinsam an Konzepten zur Risiko und
katastrophenprävention bzw zur
Bewältigung dieser Ereignisse arbeiten
ja sehr geehrte Damen und Herren diese
Kooperation zwischen dem
Bundesministerium für Landesverteidigung
und im österreichischen
Zivilschutzverband ist glaube ich ein
ganz wichtiger Schritt um die
bestehenden Synergien die es ja schon
gibt und die Kenntnisse bestmöglich zu
nutzen um den Bedrohungen unserer Zeit
wirkungsvoll begegnen zu können danke
schön
ich darf nun den Präsidenten des
österreichischen zivilschutzverbandes
Herrn Andreas hanger um seine Worte
suchen ja sehr geehrte Frau
Bundesministerin Werte Damen und Herren
liebe Medienvertreter auch von meiner
Seite darf ich natürlich einen schönen
guten Morgen wünschen und ich darf
einmal einleiten noch wirklich gleich
meine Freude Ausdruck verleihen dass sie
diese Kooperation zustande gekommen ist
vom Bundesministerin wirklich auch ein
großes Danke an dich weil ich persönlich
auch der Meinung bin dass wir gerade
wenn wir Zivilschutz wenn wir Vorsorge
diskutieren braucht es das Miteinander
bei uns in Österreich und ich möchte
einen Begriff ganz voranstellen der
lautet Eigenverantwortung
Krisenvorsorge Zivilschutz ist nicht
Aufgabe eines einzelnen einer einzelnen
Institution eines einzelnen Bundeslandes
einer einzelnen Gemeinde eines einzelnen
Haushalte sondern das liegt ganz stark
wirklich in der Eigenverantwortung jeder
Institution und jeder Familie und wir
wollen dadurch auch auf der Bundesebene
als vorzeige Beispiel vorangehen und
diese Organisation ganz ganz stark
suchen und ganz ganz stark leben weil
wir brauchen die Bundesländer in der
Krisenvorsorge wir brauchen die
Gemeinden aber wir brauchen jeden
einzelnen und es ist ja ganz einfach
unser gemeinsames Ziel die notwendigen
Voraussetzungen dafür zu schaffen dass
auch jeder dieser Verantwortung gerecht
werden kann wir haben den Schwerpunkt
bei uns im Zivilschutzverband in der
Präventionsarbeit wir versuchen die
Bevölkerung zu sensibilisieren in allen
Krisenszenarien die gegebenenfalls auf
uns zukommen können sag immer dazu das
ist eine sehr schwierige Aufgabe weil
wir uns permanent mit Fragen
beschäftigen mit Situationen die
hoffentlich nicht passieren aber
gleichzeitig kann man natürlich die
verantwortungsvolle Aufgabe wenn es dazu
kommen sollte dass wir bestmöglich dafür
vorbereitet sind
diese Grundlagen sind entsprechend hier
zu arbeiten die Frau Bundesministerin
hat auch hier schon die wesentlichen
Inhalte dieser Kooperation vorgestellt
möchte auch betonen dass wir gerade auch
als Zivilschutzverband sehr föderal
organisiert sind der wir haben die
Zivilschutz Agenten in den Ländern wir
haben hervorragend arbeitende
Landesverbände die wiederum hin zu den
Gemeinden mit den
Sicherheitsbeauftragten diese
Informationsarbeit fort leisten wollen
werde ich nun das letzte Jahr
zurückdenke haben wir drei so große
Schwerpunkte das ist natürlich das
gesamte Thema Blackout ein Thema das
gerade auch in der Zivilbevölkerung
mittlerweile einen großen Stellenwert
genießt wir haben insgesamt 800 Vorträge
über den Zivilschutzverband im vorigen
Jahr organisiert und den zweiten großen
Schwerpunkt das ist Strahlenschutz wir
kennen alle dieses Szenario dieser
unsägliche Krieg der derzeit in Europa
stattfindet könnte auch einen Unfall in
diese Richtung verursachen auch da haben
wir die Bevölkerung bestmöglich darauf
vorzubereiten und das zweite große Thema
ist der krisensichere Haushalt das heißt
wir wollen auch die Bevölkerung
individuell weil jeder Haushalt ist auch
unterschiedlich organisiert
bestmöglicher darüber informieren wie
man sich auf eine Krise insgesamt
vorbereiten kann von meiner Seite noch
einmal ein großes Dankeschön für diese
Kooperation es wird jetzt an uns liegen
dieser Kooperation auch mit sehr viel
Leben zu erfüllen als Zivilschutzverband
werden wir hier wirklich bestmöglich
versuchen zu unterstützen zu kooperieren
und ich sage noch einmal großes Danke
für die Kooperation ich halte auch
persönlich für eine unglaublich wichtige
Aufgabe die wir hier für die
österreichische Bevölkerung zu leisten
haben für Fragen stellen jetzt glaube
ich gerne zur Verfügung bevor wir zu den
Fragen schreiben würde ich sie suchen
dass wir den gemeinsamen
Kooperationsvertrag unterzeichnen und
danach haben wir noch die Möglichkeit
für etwa fragen
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren da darf
ich sie jetzt um Fragen ersuchen und
würde die beiden Vertreter wieder an die
Rednerpult bitten
ja mein Name ist Peter Unger von der
Zeit im Bild meine erste Frage sie
unterzeichnet als einen
Kooperationsvertrag wie war denn die
Zusammenarbeit bisher ich hätte mir
jetzt so ohne es zu wissen gedacht das
ist die ohnehin schon gegeben hat und
die zweite Frage Frau Ministerin Krisen
Sicherheitsgesetz das braucht es
natürlich auch das ist derzeit im
Begutachtung morgen endet die
begutachtungsfrei ist es gibt tausende
Stellungnahmen
wo Menschen befürchten dass man
sozusagen die Regierung eine Krise
aufrufen kann und totalitär agieren kann
was sagen Sie diesen Kritikern und ähm
gibt es irgendwie eine Möglichkeit dass
das Gesetz noch überarbeitet wird weil
sie brauchen ihre Zustimmung zur Zeit
Drittel mehr die es bisher nicht gibt
entweder von FPÖ oder SPÖ
ich darf vielleicht mit dem zweiten Teil
des krisensicherheitsgesetzes beginnen
sie haben es richtig angesprochen dieser
Tage endete begutachtungsfristen ich
glaube es geht bis Freitag noch am
dritten glaube ich ist die letzte
Möglichkeit diese stellungennahmen
werden dann eingearbeitet werden und
dann wird gemeinsam mit dem
Bundeskanzleramt mit dem
Innenministerium weiterverhandelt werden
worum geht es in Wahrheit geht es darum
dass wir erstmalig mit dieser
Gesetzesmaterie die Krise auch definiert
haben ich glaube wichtig ist dass man
alle Stellungnahmen genau durchschaut
durchaus auch einarbeitet und dann zu
einem Ergebnis kommt dass er nur so
lauten darf dass es besser wird dass das
Sinn dahinter soll ja sein dass wir in
der Organisation in den Abläufen einfach
besser aufgestellt sind und für uns als
österreichisches bundesherr dass wir
auch eine gesetzliche Grundlage dafür
bekommen was wir in Wahrheit im Rahmen
der Bearbeitung aller Einsätze in
Zusammenhang mit der corona-krise ja
schon gemacht haben da geht es
insbesondere um alles was die
Lagerhaltung um die Beschaffung dieser
insbesondere im Notlager die wir ja
angelegt haben und diese auch Aufgaben
auch eigenständig als eigene Aufgaben
durchführen werden können also ich hoffe
dass zum einen die eingearbeitete
Stellungnahmen und die anschließenden
Verhandlungen dann zu einem Ergebnis zu
einem positiven führen werden dass wir
einfach besser auf Krisen vorbereitet
sind und die Zusammenarbeit von
Zivilschutzverband ich habe es vorhin ja
schon angesprochen die hat
selbstverständlich auch bis jetzt
gegeben aber wir haben einfach gesehen
dass die Lage eine so viel unsichere
geworden ist das sieht man an unserem
Risiko Bild vor 25 Jahren hat er ein
Viertel der Anzahl der Krisen gegeben
und jetzt sind wir auf über 70 die als
wahrscheinlich eingeschätzt werden das
heißt die Zusammenarbeit ist zu
intensivieren wir müssen aber auch eines
machen mit dem Zivilschutzverband als
wichtigen Teil auch der umfassenden
Landesverteidigung
die müssen wir wiederbeleben wir haben
zum einen erstmalig in den Lehrplänen
der Schulen jetzt auch dieses Thema mit
drinnen und das heißt unsere
informationsoffiziere die jetzt dann
durchaus auch in den Schulen sehr
intensiv auch mit Arbeiten werden hier
auch zum Einsatz kommen es ist eine
Intensivierung auch die nicht zuletzte
da Sicherheitslage auch geschuldet ist
die in jedem Fall keine sichere ist als
sie in der Vergangenheit war
ich glaube zivilschutzfragen sind in den
letzten Jahren haben an Bedeutung
gewonnen überhaupt gar keine Frage weil
wir eben diese neuen
Bedrohungsszenarien haben durch den
unsäglichen ukraine-krieg wir natürlich
auch die Pandemie und das große
gemeinsame Ziel ist es die Gesellschaft
insgesamt resilienter gegenüber diese
Krisen zu machen und fehle auch nicht
dass wir da in Österreich meine
Einschätzung nach auch wie soll ich
formulieren bestimmte Luft nach oben
haben wenn ich nur zum Beispiel zitieren
darf ich war vorher sehr in Finnland
jetzt hat kann man Finnland Österreich
natürlich nicht miteinander vergleichen
das will ich ausdrücklich betonen ganz
andere geopolitische Situation aber dort
ist die Bevölkerung wesentlich stärker
in zivilschutzfragen engagiert in
Österreich also parlamentalität naja es
wird schon nichts passieren und ich
glaube an diesem müssen wir ein bisschen
arbeiten weil natürlich ist jederzeit
sein kann dass ein Krisenszenario
Eintritt und es ist unsere gemeinsame
Aufgabe dass wir uns bestens möglich auf
diese Krisen vorbereiten dieses
gemeinsame Ziel haben wir und an diesem
Ziel werden wir mit Nachdruck arbeiten
Carina traunerpuls24 ich hätte zwei
Fragen die erste gleich an beide der
Herr hanger hat von Eigenverantwortung
gesprochen wie sieht es denn da bei
Ihnen zu Hause aus wie haben Sie sich
auf einen Blackout vorbereitet und die
zweite Frage wäre es gibt schon eine Art
Geschäft rund um die Blackout Vorsorge
da gibt es viele Angebote auch online
die teilweise nicht so seriös sind was
kann man da Bevölkerung damit geben wo
soll man sich am besten informieren
damit man da quasi auch gut vorbereitet
ist ja vielleicht nehme ich da ähm
in die Hand
da sich zu informieren das ist wohl der
beste Weg ich persönlich mit meiner
Familie wir sind darauf vorbereitet
genau auch nach den Anleitungen
insbesondere was die Wasserversorgung
anbelangt was er die Anzahl der
Lebensmittel und in welcher Form
anbelangt das ist ohne Zweifel etwas
einfacher am Land als es das in der
gratis das war mitunter auch ein Grund
warum unsere Experten das
blackout-kochbuch herausgegeben haben wo
man sich auch anschauen kann welche
Möglichkeiten man durchaus auch in einer
in einer Wohnung hat einen entsprechende
Kochstelle auch zu schaffen und hier
vorzusorgen ich glaube das ist eben eine
Arbeit die wir zu erfüllen haben
damit eben nicht nur Geschäft da gemacht
wird damit sondern dass man tatsächlich
auch vorsorgt für seine Familie und für
sich und das ins Bewusstsein zu rufen
der Stadt war ja vor ein paar Jahren
gemeinsam auch mit einem unserer Partner
mit dem Gemeindebund wo wir das erstmals
ins Bewusstsein gerufen haben dass das
auch ein Risiko ist auf dass man sich
vorbereiten kann und wo jeder und jede
einzelne auch etwas tun kann
sie sprechen eine sehr wichtige Frage an
ich beginne mit der zweiten tatsächlich
ist es so dass natürlich diese
Unsicherheit in der Bevölkerung auch
manche motiviert in Geschäfte macherei
hineinzugehen und da übernehmen wir
glaube ich wirklich eine sehr wichtige
Aufgabe dafür erwähnen einen eigenen
zivilschutzshop im Internet der vom
oberösterreichischen Landesverband
gemacht wird und dort bewerten natürlich
unsere Experten hier sind ausschließlich
Produkte am Markt die von unseren
Experten als sachlich gerechtigt und
richtig erachtet werden wir wollen
natürlich da auch der Bevölkerung
entsprechend Sicherheit geben weil es
halt auch Experten Ebene beurteilt wird
ist das jetzt ein Produkt das genau für
diese Krisenvorsorge hilfreich ist und
wir versuchen natürlich auch durch
entsprechend Informationskampagnen hier
die Bevölkerung zu unterstützen was
meine persönliche Situation betrifft wir
machen gerade Platz für unsere jüngere
Generation zu Hause planen einen
sogenanntes kleines ausgedinger und
dieses Ausgedinge wird wirklich sehr
krisenfest sein man kann sich schon
wirklich auch heute sehr gut darüber
informieren wir werden dort auch in den
Energieerzeugung und attack sein mit
Photovoltaik ist das mittlerweile
wirklich sehr sehr einfach möglich und
wir werden dann natürlich auch da
versuchen entsprechend das Vorbild
voranzubringen
kann man das irgendwie das Risiko eines
Blackouts irgendwie an Zahlen festmachen
oder welche Parameter sind dafür
verantwortlich kann man das irgendwie
auch weiß ich nicht den Prozent sagen
wie sie sind in den letzten Jahren
geändert hat sind Frau Minister
angesprochen ein Viertel mit 70 das habe
ich jetzt nicht so ganz verstanden
ja gemeint war das Risiko Bild dass wir
in der sicherheitspolitischen
Jahresvorschau jedes Jahr präsentieren
und das hat eben vor 20 25 Jahren noch
gänzlich anders ausgeschaut es war die
Anzahl der Krisen die als wahrscheinlich
oder nicht auszuschließen mit bestimmten
Prozentsätzen im veranschlagt werden
gemeint und das sind im jetzt aktuellen
risikobild eben über 70 ich glaube genau
73 78 73 Risiken und das waren damals im
sehr viel weniger ich meine ich glaube
das ist immer eine Gradwanderung
zwischen dem was
Panikmache ist das soll es keinesfalls
sein und zwischen dem was an
Bewusstseinsbildung und an Informationen
die man dann weitergibt dass jeder auch
seinen Beitrag leisten kann unsere
europäischen Stromnetze sind nicht
schlecht unsere österreichischen
Stromnetze schon gar nicht und dennoch
ist nicht auszuschließen
begonnen von einer Naturkatastrophe über
einen Terroranschlag das eben das dazu
führen kann dass es zu einem Blackout
kommt im kleinerem Ausmaß mussten wir
schon immer Stromausfälle auch zur
Kenntnis nehmen wenn man nur daran denkt
man hat ein kleines Kind zu Hause dann
reicht muss es gar kein Blackout sein
dass über Tage geht wenn man da nicht
vorgesorgt hat Tage ob ein Blackout
konnte sondern nur die Frage wann ein
Blackout kommt
wenn ich vielleicht ergänzen darf wir
haben genau zu dieser Frage im Parlament
eine onkette durchgeführt eine
Veranstaltung und er möchte immer den
Blumen in der Christina zitieren der
technische Vorstand unserer Netze der
Austrian grippauer der sagt wir haben
einer der besten Netze auch im
europäischen Vergleich er weist aber
auch daraufhin habe gerade jetzt mit
Stolz erzählt dass ich zum Beispiel
selber eine PV-Anlage jetzt mache aber
natürlich diese vielen neuen PV-Anlagen
und auch Windräder die Energiewende das
wollen wir zu 100% führt natürlich dazu
dass unsere Stromproduktion dezentral
wird früher hat es wenige große
Kraftwerke gegeben und jetzt gibt es
viele kleine das hat natürlich bedeutet
neue Herausforderungen an unsere
Stromnetze deshalb brauchen wir auch
starke große Investitionen in die
Stromnetze aber er hat auch in diesem
Vortrag gesagt in der Modellrechnungen
wenn es zu einem Blackout kommen sollte
sind die Stromnetze dann in wenigen
Stunden wieder hochgefahren in der
Modellrechnung und er hat auch darauf
hingewiesen dass es nicht aus
zuschließen ist und wir haben natürlich
einen liberalisierten stromarkt wir
haben europäische Stromnetze aber die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist gering allerdings
kann es genauso passieren und äh diese
Aufgabe dass wir uns bestmöglich darauf
vorzubereiten wird uns natürlich nicht
abgenommen
wir haben im übrigen auch mit Austria
powergrid das war das letzte Partner
Übereinkommen dass wir abgeschlossen
haben voriges Jahr am 8 Juli
2022 weil die natürlich auch in diesem
Bereich unglaublich wichtige wichtige
Partner sind
Bernadette krasche die Presse die
verteidigungsfrau
Verteidigungsministerin hat Eva
angesprochen das ist eigentlich keine
Frage ist ob sondern wann ein Gott
eintreten könnte jetzt wird aber
gleichzeitig immer gesagt dass die
Wahrscheinlichkeit als gering
eingeschätzt wird was genau bedeutet
dass es ist jetzt ein Fakt dass es
eintreten wird oder ist es eine wie hoch
ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit wenn sie denn
noch gering ist und gibt's da
Einschätzungen dazu und noch eine zweite
Frage wie lange wäre die maximale Dauer
das Sinn einer Vorsorge ist ja so wie
bei einer Versicherung der Herr
Präsident hat sie in seinen
Eingangsworten noch angesprochen man
trifft die Vorsorge bereitet sich vor in
der Hoffnung dass eine Ereignisse eben
nicht eintritt das ist die Aufgabe dazu
wenn sie einen Prozentsatz jetzt haben
wollen dann kann ich Ihnen nur zwei
unterschiedliche der experten nennen das
eine sind eben die die sagen es wird in
jedem Fall passieren die Frage ist nur
wann es passiert und das an das andere
sind diejenigen die sagen die
Wahrscheinlichkeit liegt im unteren
Drittel es wird uns nicht erspart
bleiben egal wie lange dann ein Blackout
dauert das kann ja von bis sein wie
gesagt die kleineren mussten wir ja
schon mussten wir ja schon erleben immer
wieder auch erleben aus den
verschiedensten aus den verschiedensten
Gründen sei es jetzt da Überlastungen
der Netze oder ähnliches ich glaube das
Wichtige ist dass man eine
Bewusstseinsbildung eben macht und dass
man sich vorbereitet
das ist eine Aufgabe die wir gemeinsam
zu erfüllen haben insbesondere aber auch
eine für uns für das österreichische
Bundesheer weil wir als strategische
Reserve der Republik ja immer dann zum
Einsatz kommen wenn nichts mehr geht
oder wenn noch niemand kann das mussten
wir in den vergangenen drei Jahren so
oft erleben wie noch nie zuvor wenn Sie
daran denken an die zahlreichen Einsätze
in Zusammenhang mit der Pandemie dann
über den zweiten november den
furchtbaren
Terroranschlag wo wir nach wie vor mit
bei 900 Soldaten im Assistenzeinsatz für
die Polizei an den Botschaften die
Bewachung auch übernehmen das heißt es
geht insbesondere dann darum sich eben
vorzubereiten weil es ein Risiko ist das
nicht auszuschließen ist wenn sie sich
das Risiko Bild meiner Experten
anschauen aus dem jänner 2020 dann ist
da auch das Risiko einer Pandemie
bereits drinnen gestanden nicht so wie
es dann eingetreten ist und wo wir uns
da mitten drinnen befunden haben aber
mit einer damaligen Wahrscheinlichkeit
von 50% und daher haben wir das ernster
zu nehmen und uns eben vorzubereiten auf
alle Eventualitäten die passieren
könnten und ganz offen es hat auch
beinahe niemand für möglich gehalten
dass der Krieg wieder in dieser Form auf
den Kontinent zurückkehrt
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren nachdem es
keine weiteren Fragen gibt darf ich die
Pressekonferenz hier vor Ort für beendet
erklären und würde es ja suchen dass wir
in den Innenhof wechseln um uns hier die
weiteren Fahrzeuge des
zivilschutzverbandes